percent of guys do you think are over
six foot
one percent
lucky guess 56 56 I'm gonna say 35 35 42
42. huh
um Harmony
I'm not drunk guys
um I would say 30 30 so it's only 15 of
guys wow and now think about it think
about it if uh how many people said they
have an ax over six foot you did you did
you did all sleeping with the same guys
[Laughter]
are sleeping with the same guys because
80 of women want 20 of men
no that is mad so the reason like women
think men are trash and they think
they're sleeping around all the time is
because we go for such a small
percentage of of men and they are
sleeping around all the time yeah the
majority of men if you go to Tesco you
think they're getting a new play
okay so you'll see it and you're saying
it comes to our choice in men right that
makes us think the rest are the same I
think that's the first statement
actually yeah I agree with that
yes that's a very interesting thing
because I feel like a lot of the time
like women when they're younger yeah
they go for like the bad boy or like
something and as you get older you kind
of realize that like certain traits that
you would like find attractive like
someone who's emotionally unavailable
they become unattractive as you get
older you're only 22 right I know what
have you been in a relationship but you
know I've seen so many like people get
into relationships and it's just and it
all flops something and it's like yeah
I'm scared
I'm actually terrified so um have you
guys had a toxic ax yep yes
um it wasn't an X but I guess yeah sort
of toxic yeah okay nope I've had people
who felt like they're obliged
by having a say in my life because they
like me
yes or no I need a yes
no me I would say yeah yeah okay um how
long were you involved with your toxic
ex a year and a half yeah did you love
him yes yes five years five years oh my
oh my goodness that is mad five years
yeah that is crazy did you love him
that's how you know it's toxic five
years you didn't love him I don't know
it was I wasn't like in a relationship
with him but it was just a very toxic
situation so
okay so no you didn't love him yes or no
um I don't know maybe it was love to me
at the time at the time I don't think
his love like now when I look back on it
okay wow five years okay so I actually
have not been in a relationship like
properly where I can say oh you know
with boyfriend and girlfriend yeah but
I've been in a lot of situations where
I'm thinking again and I would say yeah
I must go and it's been quite toxic so
yeah you would yes yes and how long were
you with him
oh
I was with him for about
must be not five months not long five
months yeah I'm a busy woman I haven't
really got time did you did you love him
no no
okay so question question based on this
panel two out of four of you said you
loved your toxic acts and you were with
him for over a year would you say by
that statement young women love toxic
men
yes yes do you know what it is I think
when you're young you don't really know
your boundaries properly yet and a lot
of people put up with stuff that they
wouldn't usually put up with like I
always say now like men only treat you
bad if you let them if you let them yeah
if you let them treat you man and you
don't if you don't respect your
boundaries then they're gonna walk all
over you and I think that's just bad
guys though I think that's just bad guys
like I think there's something about
young women like picking the Bad Boys
you know like I don't think we're gonna
walk all over you if you treat them well
that's just yeah no 100 I'm the youngest
in here and I will tell you yeah it's
because it's exciting it's like almost
like an adrenaline
bounce off each other I knew it when she
was talking about the following I was
like she likes to draw
literally but I also feel like yeah it's
not sorry I also feel like it depends on
your circumstances as the young girl
because I with me I depended on my ex
for Living For food for everything so I
felt like I was chained to him like I
was his had no one else you know so it
was like circumstances made me and be in
that situation so what about that
situation was toxic uh well he was
basically like cheating around flirting
with other girls at work
um I didn't know obviously because I was
just like at home I didn't have a job I
was just like living off him you know
but I feel like he he
um had that power over me because I
allowed him to obviously so yeah so she
was it more than cheating or was he a
good boyfriend outside of it it was more
than cheating I was involved in certain
things as well so I felt like if he did
if if he could do I could do it to you
okay so you were cheating you were both
cheating on each other and couldn't you
just done a standstill and then got
along and
um no because I mean
we did have conversations about it we we
were very open with each other but then
obviously the cheating was lies he
because he kept it from me so did you
keep your cheating from him no I told
him I told him you don't know you don't
want to know who I cheated on him with
but um
no he's not no no no okay I'm scared do
I know no you don't know
okay I cheated on him with his sister
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm a changed person I am a changed
person I'm a change okay so what
why why is sister I'm just gonna set my
dream me and his sister were really good
friends I mean clearly
what no no worry
friends
and obviously one day she said she
wanted to come over and I said cool he
was at work we got drunk and she started
like pouncing on me
okay I'm not even trying to like I'm so
serious like she and I was like no like
this isn't right and she's like no and
then Boop it happened and I was like
[__] and then you told him yeah I told
him how did he react he almost killed me
was she younger how old was she she was
younger yeah but we had a conversation
about it and
I can't be out of his ethnicity anyway
um it's it's almost like common from
where he's from
wearing that
so
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's not common but it was like a thing
within his
[Laughter]
because I'm regardless of whether I did
something wrong or not regardless of
whether I hurt someone's feeling or not
I am an honest person and I feel like
that's very very important if you're if
you're talking to someone if you're in a
relationships with someone if you're
just with people anyway you know so I I
just I clarified that with him he got
upset he came back and he was like thank
you for being honest with me you know so
it was like yeah but he was toxic for
cheating on you and not telling you yes
I had to find out would you would you
rather have him told you yes do you
think men lie to women they care about
or that they or they tell the truth to
women they lie to women they care about
and they feel like maybe like certain
characteristics that they have for
example
um some because some women are really
Stern like if you cheat on me that's it
and because they care so much they don't
want to lose you so that thought of
having to lose you would now be in be in
their head obviously and yeah they
wouldn't they wouldn't tell you so
outside of the cheating anything else
toxic or just that
um
yeah we smoked a lot of stuff
okay so I guess that's drugs
I guess that was toxic here okay
um all right what about you
um
what was the question
um what was toxic about you said you had
a toxic situationship yeah what was
toxic about it um it was very
emotionally abusive so like even I see
myself as a strong person but there's
only so many times you can like get
knocked down and I've dealt with it and
I feel like I didn't respect my own
boundaries which led to me being in that
situation
um yeah it was just very unhealthy what
is emotional abuse
um I think to constantly knock someone's
confidence down make them feel bad about
themselves
like what specifically
um
I don't know like it could really be
anything like you know just I'm asking
like to you like what did he say like
what how was he emotionally abusive oh
he just like just used to knock me down
like I used to be a bit slow because I
had a history of like doing like party
drugs okay I feel like it actually
affected my like mental development a
bit like I had a stutter for a long time
like I was a bit slow and it was one of
my biggest insecurities and I used to
get digged out a lot for that like oh
you're so slow you're stupid you know
this and that's what he would say to you
yeah and also
um I lost a lot of weight because of
stress and I was very insecure in my
skin like you're so skinny like lost so
much weight and it just makes you feel
like a bit rubbish about myself
um and what did what did you say to him
back like did you push back or what yeah
I would push back I would tell him like
don't talk to me like that or I don't
like that I'm running because he did
used to like threaten me and stuff but
he used to threaten you yeah he was he
wasn't like threatened threatened to do
like what kill you or no like just to
like you know bring his fists up to me
and stuff I knew he would never do
anything but like yeah it was just not a
nice situation I would always Stand My
Ground about that but I would continue
to put up with it for so long so that's
why
like I was disrespected for so long but
literally after I got out of it I put on
weight like I was I got a glow like life
is good we love our happy ending yeah
um what about no you you said yes you
were maybe
[Music]
yeah
I relate to her as well because you know
what it is now I'm hearing both stories
maybe I haven't actually been a little
toxic um relationship we say or toxic X
but everyone has their own meaning of
toxic at the end of the day obviously
I'm sure there is like a meaning by book
but everyone has their lacking yeah yeah
yeah you know what I'm trying to say but
yeah basically I think with me obviously
um it wasn't for that long I think that
I think was toxicity is like he was
saying he wanted to see me but didn't
see me and this was like that for about
eight months so he would say he'd want
to see you and then he wouldn't see you
next plans of you and lets you down
with me you cannot take a bite with me
I'll be like leave then stop leading me
what I said I'm not leaving you off have
you ever um promised to go on a date and
not get what not went have you ever worn
off a guy for a date yeah are you guys
all toxic yeah yeah
yeah but women aren't demonized for it
men are we call it entertainment
[Laughter]
like a rotation entertainment hahaha but
when a guy says that he's toxic yeah
that's absolutely because he says the
exact same thing that women can be just
as bad as men though some women are
actually demons like yeah evil pure evil
yeah tell me who are you thinking of
what story
no I've just like seen how like some
women treat men and like you know
um some women can be very narcissistic I
think
social media especially has like become
a breeding ground for narcissism in a
lot of people but I do also think the
times thrown around very Loosely and a
lot of people are accused of being a
narcissist when they're actually not
never what girl you said you could think
of a narcissistic girl sort of story
yeah
[Music]
um I mean I could use like my
I don't know I don't know any
narcissistic women like hard stories oh
you've heard stories I've Heard lots of
stories and it's it's actually like
heartbreaking because a lot of the time
these men really care for these women
unless they're trapped in this abusive
you know what a lot of girls trap guys
by getting pregnant they do it happens a
lot and then they have all this baby mum
and dad's almost like it's mad no but do
you know what it is yeah when it comes
to like trapping a man with a baby you
need to be careful who you sleep with if
you're sleeping with people Loosely and
you you run the risk of getting that
person pregnant so you have to you have
to sit like you don't get back remember
we said earlier about if you you're only
going into placement date that person
you don't that person you want to be
with them and you're getting very short
because of trust and then you'd only
speak with that person if you're like
jumping in that yeah at the same time at
the same time if you don't want to make
anything you need to wrap up because
yeah yeah as much as it takes two to
tango you need to protect yourself for
your own good like yeah yeah the woman
can say she's on the pill she's on this
she's on that but like but still at the
same time protect yourself yes you said
you've you've heard of a girl trapping a
guy tell me about that oh
yeah we're just baiting people's
businesses
[Music]
um as many of you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible